- I have to, look, I have
to bring this up because
we were both at the
Christmas tree lighting.
I was most excited, like, they were like,
will you host the show?
I was like sure, yeah, I love it.
Like, I love Christmas.
I was most excited.
(audience cheering)
This is me dancing,
singing every damn word.
I'm not kidding, I wore my sister out
with your song at Thanksgiving.
Like, it came out in October and I
I literally told my, I was like,
please get her on the show.
I was like, I, this is the
DJ Play A Christmas Song,
I'm gonna say it, fight me on it.
It's the greatest Christmas song
to come out since All I
Want For Christmas Is You.
(audience cheering and clapping)
It's the greatest contemporary
Christmas song to come out.
Like, I love it so much,
it makes me so happy.
I'm not kidding, I've
sent videos to my friends.
Like Blake Shelton and Nile.
They've, I've hit them up so much with
videos of me just singing your song.
- Good.
- Yeah, it's so good!
- But you know what, that's what I wanted.
That's the reason I never
made a Christmas album before
was 'cause I couldn't find, in my mind,
I couldn't find a way to put myself into,
to a Cher Christmas, you know?
So then I found these, I found my.
A girl I've known since
I, she was four years old,
sent me that song and,
- It's so good.
- And I didn't even know it was her,
Sara Hudson four years old,
Sara Hudson big writer, whatever.
- Yeah.
- So I got that, and then all of a sudden
I started to kind of not, you know how
your mind is thinking, but
you're not aware of it.
- Yeah.
- But so then I thought about
doing the song with Darlene.
- Oh, I did not know
the backstory on that,
that you originally
did, I didn't know that.
- [Cher] No.
- I love that you sang the backgrounds
and then y'all twisted it and
now she's singing it with you.
- Right, no, and I, because
I wasn't gonna do it
unless she wanted to sing it with me.
Because somehow it just
wouldn't have been right.
But on this, one of the songs on my album,
Darlene Love, who sings
Baby Please Come Home
and everybody knows it,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
- Yeah.
- When I was 17, I did
the background on it.
So when we came together with it,
- I never knew this!
- It was really, it was really good.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- I never knew that.
I think I heard you say that on Fallon,
and I was like, I never knew that.
I think that's incredible.
- No, but how would you
know this like nameless,
faceless little kid get in the back.
- I know, but it plays.
- Cher could you just step back,
Cher could you just step back?
(audience laughing)
- No!
- Cher, could you just
sing a little softer?
- No, but that, oh, that's
been my thing my whole life.
They're like, you're too loud, blend.
- Right.
- You know, you're excited.